hello everyone welcome to this recorded
lecture although this can never really
replace the effectiveness of
face-to-face learning in a real
classroom but given the very special
circumstances we find also saying let us
try to make the best use of whatever we
have so without much further ado let us
get on with the lecture in the first
week after mid semester we started with
the chapter on the analysis of stress so
let's put that down
in the second week we went on to a
discussion of strains and
and stress-strain relations in this
third week
what we are going to start is a
discussion on the transformation of
stresses so this is the plan for this
week
now this is a topic which is used by
practicing engineers on a day to day
basis and even from a non mechanical
engineering non civil engineering non
aerospace engineering perspective this
has some relevance from the point of
view that the the higher end stuff of
these transformation of stresses as well
as transformation of strains which we'll
learn later it has connections with
linear algebra which finds use in almost
all branches of engineering so this
gives us really a headway in two really
really useful widely used mode of study
so let's try to see what this is all
about transformation of stresses to
really get into the the important
concept of transformation of stresses we
have to first very briefly recap what we
had studied in the first week while
discussing the chapter on the analysis
of stress so there we had learned that
we had learned the concept of the state
of stress so we briefly recap that
so there we had seen and while
discussing the concept of state of
stress that if we have a three
dimensional body let's use a different
color here so maybe be red for our axis
so if you have this kind of a
three-dimensional body which is acted
upon by various externally applied
forces let's say
and we want to investigate what happens
to a point which is placed inside this
three dimensional body so let's say a
point Q which is inside this body so
what we did back when discussing the
concept of the state of stress was to
take first of all the plane which was
parallel to the Y Z plane so we'll just
name or axis here so this was X this was
Y this was said so we took a plane which
was parallel to the Y Z plane and which
happened to be passing through the point
Q so it took something like this so this
plane was passing through the point Q
and it caught our three dimensional body
over this cutting plane and what we did
next was to isolate the left hand side
part of this three dimensional body
which would look something like this
we understand that this is very much an
imaginary cut what cue is still here so
this plane is parallel to the Y Z plane
now what we recognize first of all was
that we still had these external forces
acting outside we don't see these two
forces that the other there are the
three forces because they are acting on
the right-hand part and we are not
trying that now to balance these
externally applied forces that we can
see here this one and this one we need a
distribution of internal forces acting
on this surface the surface which has
just been exposed what we did back then
and we're not going to go into the
details of that again we took a very
small area around the point Q and we
focused on the effective force for the
resultant force that is acting on that
very very small area at the point Q and
we deprecated something like this
so this is an internal force this
green-colored for arrow represents an
internal force our next step was to take
the component of this screen current
internal force along the X direction so
it depicted here again and the next
thing we did was to take the component
of this force again this internal force
again this one along this exposed
surface on which Q is line so we're
going to take the component of this
force on this plane so that sorry so
that is going to look something like
this
so we understand that this force that we
have just drawn this is lying on the
plane that has been freshly exposed
depicted by the red colored boundary so
one of these components is along the x
direction and this one is along the
plane but this is neither along the Y
direction nor along the Z direction and
what we did next was to take the
component of this along the Y and then
along the Z so it took this two
components so the original internal
force let's say this is P this gets
expressed in terms of px
and
and a fee this V further gets expressed
in terms of
py and PZ so what we did after this was
to express stress components in terms of
this px this V Y and this V said and
what we said was that the Sigma xx would
be defined as limit a tends to 0 px by a
the Sigma X Y or tau X Y would be limit
a tends to 0 py PI a and Sigma X Y or
sorry
Sigma X ed or tau X said is equal to
limit a tends to 0 VZ divided by a now
the most important thing to note here is
that all these definitions of Sigma xx
Sigma XY or tau X Y and Sigma X ed or
tau XZ depends very much in the way that
we have chosen our x y&z coordinates
what I want to have emphasized here is
that if for instance we had taken a
different orientation of our x y&z axis
then the components px the component P Y
and the component P said they would be
completely different even though we
would be still addressing the same three
dimensional body acted upon by the three
same set of externally applied forces
depicted by this blue arrows here so the
same three dimensional body acted on by
three by all the same forces can show
different stress components at a
particular point if we choose to work
with different coordinate directions and
that is a very very important point so
the state of stress is very much very
much dependent on what kind of
coordinate directions we are taking